let your minds go wild and crazy think
about what you'd like to rap about
there's there's no rules sometimes I'm
like no food no animals but no I trust
all of you to come up with original
creative suggestions best suggestion
ever was 9th century crop rotation
second best was a German man who said a
day into life of an Aztec high priest
English boy
you get like five suggestions we'll come
to this segment here so if you are in
this kind of arm range talk to you like
a rap battle
the bubonic play thank you very much for
clarifying what type of play
if you wanted to play
um famously ended by The Great Fire of
London in 1666
um
just sits at home and giggles at
Wikipedia
thank you that's a great topic for us
because it's nice to do creative perhaps
that no one's ever raped about that
before so good let's come to this
segment here front to the back wherever
you are looks like wrap up
crumbs in my butter crumbs in your
butter that's such a kitten angry
it was almost if you were like why
didn't you suggest this yourself Chris
that is the problem we all need to be
tackled in the front in your butter
um how do you keep your butter sir
in the fridge in the fridge was actually
first mistake right not not for crumbs
just for you know you shouldn't you
should keep her in a stoneware butter
dish
I'm from Manchester and I hate myself
right now
phrase that came out of my mouth
man who worked night shifts in Tesco's
for two years is now telling someone
what to do with her spreadable Dairy
crumbs in your butter I am grateful for
that let's come to this section there
was like about that
failed experiments by flat earth
scientists are you referring to the guy
who built the rocket and then shot it
because he was like oh see I'm gonna
prove it and then it crashed and he
didn't die I think he was just quite
grievously injured okay if he did die
let's imagine he was just greatly
injured because then we can laugh at it
even if he did die [ __ ] him he's an
idiot right and so far crumbs in your
butter fail Flat Earth experiments
Bubonic plague I'm blanking you know if
this is good don't [ __ ] it up and say
dogs
[Music]
Margaret Thatcher's evil twin I like it
these These are spectacular suggestions
and the problem is because sometimes
like when the suggestions are [ __ ] then
if the rat's a bit average I can be like
oh well the suggestions were [ __ ] I
really want to do these uh the opposite
of a disservice I don't think it's
service
I want to do these Justice thank you
very much yeah cool great [ __ ] unless
that was just a protester just shouting
out
Justice for the baby
okay moist socks Margaret Thatcher's
evil twin but uh crumbs in my butter the
Bubonic plague and the other one we got
in the middle which was fail fail planet
Earth experiments
maybe that one no no no no no okay I was
playing now okay we're doing this one
fine [ __ ] it it's gonna be fun
no no they took the words
oh yes
[Music]
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you Chris I went over
there and I opened the fridge and I just
started crumbling in order to go moving
the bread in there I'm like oh what am I
gonna do what I do now go off to the
shop in the produce a cow bringing it
home I don't want it spoiled
rest in the foil and Michelle came down
like the guy does but I still open it
and there's no white cars there's a
moment would be getting in from that
style with no starter so I'm like this
guy's evil like Archer part of it is the
first name only one of her but it's a
shame if you have some idea that she'd
be in that pool but she has an evil twin
it's not a British yes it's really
unpathetic if you think of people not
protector that's a double negative Evil
by her own virtue so to be evil when
your evil are true what does all she
would be as good as gold she's like I'm
the iron lady that I've been told and I
I am lady I mean 18 creases out to leave
sure he says mean things from her mouth
like steel the milk from the babies from
Crown either too well cause I'm crazy I
know this one's energy Margaret crashes
no evil twin she's very well behaved to
be ruling released from 79 to later I'd
say
doesn't
[Music]
does
[Music]
his home that brought his own spacecraft
doesn't even trust Elon Musk and it lost
and anywhere bust like no have you
started parachuting he was cooking round
he
[Music]
of course who deserves it being in the
ground or the gravity of money is now
his experiment failed should the wall
chainmail but why did the shrapnel and
he was impaled that just made him all
the [ __ ] up if I got a little wish I'll
be taking it off from like me I need to
change my clothes it's got a horrible
load of approaching my nose daring at
the brothers the rain don't stop puppy
walking in my sandals I'll be damning
but my socks so wet and it ain't even my
choice like a German sausage and sandals
their voice I like to wear the ankle one
with no height there's such a death you
can't see it tonight but these they're
not moist as well not
show that he puzzled in with sweat and
gotta take them off and I give him a
spin that's in the moment of the sink
and I give him a ring like I'm there on
the phone squeezing it out that was
binding the one oh yes it was a route of
the human race like Millions died they
were there in the streets on the bodies
on fire like oh [ __ ] bring out your dead
look at them with the bugles on their
head they're usually
[Music]
a tissue a tissue We All Fall Down hard
but whoa who's saving the day it's good
not a Hatcher she's on the way oh her
very own time machine she's back there
in the past right I'm the queen while
you're not that wouldn't make any sense
everybody in the streets yet they're
getting real tests and that should come
there she digs and she yells and she
solves the play with a shot of B12
because she had to be 12 injections in
her buttocks there you go
[Applause]